david bonjour alors quelle est
l'atmosphère sur place à une heure du
couvre-feu
eh bien écoutez à l'atmosphère sur place
et est plutôt calé là c'est surtout la
fin de la manifestation puisque les
forces de l'ordre ont opéré à la
dispersion des manifestants vous le
voyez dernièrement un important
dispositif de sécurité a été mis en
place pour disperser les derniers
manifestants en tout cas ce cortège d'un
contrôle la loi sécurité globale s'est
déroulée de manière assez un festif pas
de débordements à noter malgré bien sûr
la présence comme d'habitude de certains
pas d'élément perturbateur qui n'ont pas
agi en tout cas en ce samedi et la
manifestation a pu se dérouler et dans
le calme et dans un ambiance plutôt
festive vous le disait encore une fois
le préfet didier lallement à venir tous
les moyens matériels et humains pour
éviter justement les violences qui
avaient émané à lors des dernières
manifestations contre la loi sécurité
globale la convergence des luttes la
convergence des forces en tout cas
c'était l'objectif
aujourd'hui de la plupart des
manifestants un présent les syndicats
étaient là allez gilet jaune également
et beaucoup d'étudiants
je vous propose d'écouter à deux
syndicats présents pour lutter contre
cette loi sécurité globale on est très
content d'avoir mobilisé un nouveau
parce qu'on n'était pas redescendu dans
la rue depuis 5 décembre
malheureusement il ya eu à paris en tout
cas 5 décembre
des échauffourées qui nous ont empêché
de terminer la manifestation donc là on
est très contentes d'avoir rappelé et
d'avoir une cette mobilisation à paris
au syndicat national des journalistes où
on exige le retrait de cette proposition
de loi qui est attentatoire à la liberté
de la presse et plus globalement qui est
aussi une atteinte aux libertés
publiques
les libertés fondamentales dans ce pays
la démocratie est en danger que le droit
de s'exprimer et en danger qu'on donne
beaucoup de poids des à des lois qui
sont totalement liberticide ça fait
plaisir à voir c'est que les gens vont
pas lâcher quoi plus de deux ans chez
les jaunes on recommence une année qui
risque d'être une année catastrophe et a
je crois que bon on est à une population
qui a bien conscience de ce qui est en
train de se passer et ben voila moi je
vois de plus en plus de jeunes visages
de visages nouveaux
va falloir qu'à un moment ou presque aux
gars de moins se poser les bonnes
questions même si je crains
malheureusement qu'ils soient pas dotés
du beaune du bon outillage pour pouvoir
percevoir les vrais elle besoin de ce
citoyen voilà malgré des conditions
météo difficiles à la mobilisation était
à tous rendez vous encore une fois pour
ce projet doit de sécurité globale pour
lutter en tout cas contre le vote de cet
de cette loi elle l article 24 acquis à
pose problème et qui fait toujours débat
à l'assemblée de nombreux élus
politiques étaient également présents
dans le cortège dont hériteraient lé
député france insoumise
en tout cas l'objectif est clair pour
ces manifestants vous le voyez derrière
moi c'est cette manifestation qui touche
à sa fin en tout cas et l'objectif est
clair c'est le retrait pur et simple de
ce projet de loi la sécurité globale
merci david pour toutes ces précisions